there's no such thing to me as an
embarrassing moment no such thing v
tripped and fell if my bra strap showed
if my flip fell off if I fell flat on my
face there's no such thing as an
embarrassing moment when you think about
what it means to be a human being on the
planet roof right now that's pretty
awesome money's worth nothing if it
can't buy you the opportunity to love
more she's best known for her talk show
which was the highest rating TV program
of its kind several assessments ranked
her as the most influential woman in the
world
she's been ranked as the richest
african-american of the 20th century
she's Oprah Winfrey and here's my take
on her top ten rules of success vol 2
rule number five is my personal favorite
and I'm curious to know which one you
guys like the best and as always guys as
you're watching the videos if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well also as you are
writing something down it's much more
likely to stick in your head to enjoy
[Music]
I think that success is a process and I
believe that my first Easter speech and
the Kosciusko Baptist Church at the age
of three and a half was at the beginning
and that every other speech every other
book I read every other time I spoke in
public was was a building block so that
by the time I first sat down to audition
in front of a television camera and
somebody says read this what allows me
to read it so comfortably and be so at
ease with myself at that time the fact
that I've been doing in a while if I'd
never read a book I've never spoken in
public before I would have been
traumatized by it so the fact that we
went on the air with The Oprah Winfrey
Show in 1986 nationally and people say
oh but you should call your so
comfortable in front of camera you can
be yourself well it's because I've been
being myself since I was 19 and I would
not have I would not have been able to
be as comfortable with myself had I not
made mistakes on the air and been
allowed to make mistakes on the air and
understand that it doesn't matter you
know I there's no such thing to me as an
embarrassing moment no such thing if I
tripped and fell if my bra strap showed
if my flips fell off if I fell flat on
my face
there's no such thing as an embarrassing
moment because I know that there is not
a moment that I could possibly
experience on the air that somebody else
hasn't already experienced so when it
happens you say oh my lip fell off and
it's no big deal I mean like I was on TV
the other day in places all over you
have a run have you not seen a run the
hole in your life well I get them to let
me tell you so me mystic guy I can't be
embarrassed I can't be embarrassed now
when I first started out that was not
true because I was under think I was
pretending to be somebody I was not I
was pretending to be Barbara Walters so
I'd go to a news conference and I was
more interested in how I phrased the
question and how eloquent the questions
mounted as opposed to listening to the
answer I saw what
which always happens when you're
interested in impressing people instead
of doing which was supposed to be going
and it took me a while it took me
messing up on the air on during a live
newscast I was doing a list of foreign
countries I was all these foreign names
and then Canada was thrown in and I call
Canada Canada and I got so tickled that
I called Kenna I thought that wasn't
Kannada that was camel ah excuse me
that wasn't kind of Bible that was a
Kannada that was Canada and then I
started laughing well it was it was it
became a mutt became the first real
moment I ever had and the news director
later said to me well if you do that
then you should just keep going you
shouldn't correct yourself and let
people know I know who's ever heard our
kannada so that was for me the beginning
of realizing that oh you can laugh at
yourself and you can make a mistake and
it's not the end of the world you don't
have to be perfect
and biggest lesson for me for
televisions because then it didn't
matter doesn't matter outside bra
structuring what inspired me was um and
is continues to be what continues to
inspire me is a primal and fundamental
desire to fulfill the highest expression
of myself as a human being I don't want
to die not having completely burn out
every single possibility of my humanity
I just I just want to I leave this
planet I want everybody did that used it
all up not another thing I could do
there was an another person I could have
given of myself too there wasn't another
deed I could have done
there was a minute that you just want it
you want to say I want to fill it up you
want to take this whole human existence
which when you think about it Godfrey is
really pretty damn miraculous but is it
is it is when you think about what it
means to be a human being on the planet
Earth right now that's pretty awesome so
I just want to I want I want to I want
to take that to the max I want to say no
need to come back as a human angel
status
hate this phrase but what is your brand
do you think oh I'm the love bread oh we
all darling no love the love are you all
about the love bread you like to shower
love around them yeah it's really that's
what it is I am the love and love gone
brand that's why you're bid like Barry
White was the love god you're the love
brand I'm the love brand because
ultimately everything that I'm saying
whether it's in my magazine whether it's
Gayle on the radio whether it's the
Oprah Winfrey Show and now everything
about the channel own it's about opening
your space your heart space so that you
can love more you know that's really all
money is for money's worth nothing if it
can't buy you the opportunity to love
more I can't call in sick you can't ever
give less than 100% and if you are sick
which I have been a couple of times
that's when you got to pull up to 110
120 because people have come from all
over the country and this is their
moment they saved their money they
bought the airline tickets they got new
outfits they call their sisters or
cousins they're on their mother-in-law's
their mothers and that is why they're
there to see you so I feel a sense of
responsibility a sense of obligation a
sense of respect reverence honor for
those people first day I went to school
I was in a classroom by the time I was
uh you know six years old didn't go
school I was teaching show because as
well as my grandmother their time sure
but she had taught me how to read read
the Bible Bible stories so I went into
the classroom knowing Nicodemus Shadrach
Meshach and Abednego I could spell all
those words I thought I was you know I
was preaching to the to my kindergarten
teacher at Dover she's like who is
dessert so I was never placed in an
environment where I was ever made to
feel inferior I always felt like I'm the
smartest kid in this room and because I
would never place it in it but never put
in a position where I was made to feel
less than
I didn't grow up feeling less than you
know and the rest of this day is history
and the registers and it's all about
what you believe you know I say this too
when I do something on my network now
call life class the fundamental key to
success is what you believe is true for
yourself not what you want not what your
desire is what do you believe you know
you can say I wanted I want to be the
most successful person in the world but
if you believe that there's a glass
ceiling and you're going to have a hard
time taking through that glass ceiling
figure you will be defined by the glass
ceiling and the great beauty and gift of
my life is that I was never defined by
the box that other people tried to put
me in same comes with the mission and
purpose you know you cannot define me or
try to put me in a box and you can't
look at my life unless you look at the
whole life so I am a Negro formerly born
in 1954 in Mississippi
at a time when it was an apartheid state
and to be sitting here with you as your
first guest in 2011 is a miracle that is
beyond anything I could actually do for
myself so there's something greater at
work here and the thing that's greater
at work the force that has and forces
that have made this happen in my life
along with me working as hard as I have
it's bigger than it's bigger than I am
and fame is is the vehicle from which I
get to have this platform so do I like
that I appreciate it
if I had been what I thought I was going
to be and that is a great fourth grade
teacher I would have also liked that
because it Accord me I am a teacher and
I am happiest when I feel that people
are getting something learning something
and
sensing themselves in a way that they
never thought of before that's really
truly one of my favorite moments on
television or in any experience when I'm
just one-on-one with a friend or
somebody I don't even know being able to
share something with a man dating I
never thought it key Dedmon and I were
in a hotel watching some bad television
and I was complaining about the state of
television talk shows in particular and
he said why don't you change it why
don't you just get your own Network and
I thought that that was a ridiculous
idea and then he started to talk about
it and he wrote some things down and I
saw the word own that's an old Oh W oh
that's my those are my initials and I
said wouldn't it be something if I could
create a network that was really about
mindful and I underlined the word
mindful television fifteen years later
those scribblings came closer to reality
when she was approached by David's as
one of the president of the Discovery
Network my view was if we want to do
this you have to be all that she paused
and then she said to me it's meant to be
and we shook hands and that's how I
journeyed again at first I saw a great
network oh gee this is the dream I had
and I actually showed him the piece of
paper where I had written it down and
said mintus and as that started to
settle in with me I thought whoa what is
this
I've gotten myself into this is a lot
more work than I ever imagined are you
scared very scared I was very scared and
I would wake up in the middle of the
night literally like clutching my chest
like what have I done what have I done
what if you fail hmm that's what I was
afraid of that's what I was afraid of
the reason why I made the decision to go
forward is because I believe that people
deserve to have value centered
inspirational programming for themselves
I believe that television has become in
many ways banal it has become
insipid and not not all of it but I
think that I have something to offer I
did this at the end of my show I did my
favorite guest of all times that's hard
to do out of literally thousands and
thousands are supposedly estimated that
there's like 35,000 people I interviewed
over the years but there was one woman
out of all the celebrities out of all of
the famous non famous infamous people
one woman who was she her name is Tara
Trent listen to the story I'm going to
try to shorten it for you guys right
okay
Tara white red born and raised in a
village in Zimbabwe eleven years old
she's doing her brother's homework she
wants to go to school her father says no
you Gayle you have to educate the boys
yes that's right attribution that's
right the boy has to go to school you
can't go to school so she starts doing
her brothers homework she does his
homework he goes to school he gets
always on his homework yet he doesn't
know the answer to the question the
teacher comes to the village to say what
is going on here this boy doesn't know
the answers but it all works perfect she
finds out that terrorize his younger
sister doing his homework she begs the
father to let Tara right go to stroke
school the father says no she can't go
to school
finally he marries her off she marries
at 11 and a half years old she gets
married she has three children by the
time she's 18 years old a woman come to
the village from an NGO pepper
International and asked what are your
dreams this gonna make me cry
finally never cry I don't know what are
your dreams this child has never thought
about what her dreams were she says
write down your dreams she writes down
her dreams on a piece of paper and she
folds them in a tin can and she buries
them under a rock the first dream was to
be able to go to the school and you go
to a school in the United States of
America and get a college degree she
ends up through some miracle of the NGO
going to United States she gets a
college degree
Wow yes she gets a four-year degree in
three years
Tara Trent
she goes back to the rock in Zimbabwe
she writes her next goal on the piece of
paper she buries it under the rock
she writes I want to get a master's
degree she goes back in there is a she
got her master's degree by this time she
now has five children she's married to a
man who's incredible she goes back here
I say she gets a master's degree after
the master's degree she goes back to the
rock in Zimbabwe she writes down her
final goal is to get a doctorate degree
and last year she became dr. Tara Trent
where did you find it what did I find it
um I found her and the Nicholas
Kristof's book called
something the sky underneath the sky or
the sky Nicolae found her and Nicholas
Kristof Florida and I was reading the
story I had Nicholas Kristof on the show
Nicholas Kristof the famous New York
Times writer and she wasn't there she
wasn't a part of the check I'm reading
this - I can't believe this book the
story of this woman as I'm reading the
story so when we go to do the show the
producers have Nicholas Kristof on they
bring on other guests but this woman
isn't there I call how could you not
have her there so we take another show
with Nicholas Kristof we go back and go
fine we're going to find that woman
terror right trend this time by this
time she's living a United States we
followed her back to Zimbabwe to the
rock we pulled the pin can from
underneath the rock and that is my
favorite guest of all time Underwood I
don't have a word I don't have a word
but the reason why she and as I said
this on my show so reason why terror
right Trent is my favorite guest of all
time is because she represents in that
one story of the little girl in a
village in Zimbabwe who had a dream and
the heart and depth and discipline to
pursue it she represents everything I
tried to say in every show in 25 years
she literally through her life story
sums up the message that I was trying to
give to every single one of my viewers
you can you can
keep trying don't give up you have to
believe you have to believe the thing
that I do best piers you didn't ask me
that question
Oprah what is it you do best Oprah what
did you do back the thing that I that I
strive to do best is be here me now
right here right now with you the reason
why we've had such a good time is
because I'm not thinking about somebody
else is but I'm not thinking about how
much time do we have left and how many
questions you have and what are you
going to ask me just be here be now so
that I can enjoy this experience and so
I don't have a lot of I don't live in
the past I don't carry the past into
this moment because I do the open show I
learned how not to do that that's what
all of those years of non therapy but
paying attention to the guests on the
show the way they live their lives what
the experts had to say what I've learned
from paying attention I
benefic look like Oprah Winfrey here
town yeah
we're here you mean the penis
yeah nobody has ever said back to the I
been talking to people and nobody has
ever said you be the penis back to the
letter I wrote to Anthony ot I was such
a geek okay on today June 22nd 1971 I've
decided to voice my thoughts on paper to
prevent my brain from becoming disrupted
[Applause]
that was in high school you know in high
school doing 20sec hmm she's always been
very dramatic don't you know today is my
ninth anniversary is Anthony nine months
today never thought I'd make it this far
my father says oh there we were is this
me with the flip there was a Marlo
Thomas that girl flip my father says
stay at home and rest doesn't he know
that love knows no rest
nice best answer that for those who love
time is not I love Anthony I really
truly truly love him truly truly truly
and I don't give a blank I use the
blanks in case my father ever found the
letters a would it be cursing whether or
not people think it's proper or whether
I'm too aggressive or flipped for him
because I don't think God will mind
there's some there's so much hatred in
the world
I should think God would be happy to see
a little love flowing every night
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed this vol 2 edition if
you liked it you might want to check out
vol 1 as well it was pretty spectacular
I'd also love to know what an Oprah
state that had the biggest impact on you
and why what are you going to take from
this video and immediately apply to your
life or to your business leave it down
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do I also want to give a quick
shout-out to maria-paz guys thank you so
much for picking up a top of my book
gear one word and for making that really
fun and interesting promo picture for it
I really appreciate the love that you
put into it thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
what people don't know because you can't
tell everybody I am Who I am one black
woman my hand in God's hand trusting in
that word because that word never failed
me and I got to where I am and I stand
as I am as Maya Angelou often says and
often said and says in her poem to our
grandmothers every time you see me I
come as one but I stand as 10,000 every
time you see me I come as one but I
stand as 10,000 so it's just not me
standing up here it's every it's my
mother
my grandmother her mother the mother
before her her grandfather every uncle
who prayed every sister who cried every
aunt who sacrificed those whose names
made the history books those whose names
never could make the history books who
allowed me to come as one and stand as
10,000 so oftentimes when I walk into a
room just as cool as you please and I
can't see another black face in a 50
mile radius
I stand and sit at the board as one but
I'm bringing the 10,000 behind me
because I not only know who I am but I
also know who I am and so anything you
hear about me that feels good sounds
good you think about wonder what Oprah's
doing how's she going I I am living the
dream and I want you to live the dream
because I'm not living the dream because
I'm special I'm living the dream because
I was obedient to the call of the dream
so I want you to leave here today
thinking about what is the dream for you
what is God's dream for you what does
the creator's dream hold for you
often we spend our lives wishing and
hoping and hoping and wishing and
desiring things this is what I know for
sure you don't get what you wish for you
don't even get what your hope for you
get what you believe so what is it you
believe and know to be God's dream for
you so I live in the dream I'm living in
the space of the dream and dreams good
dreams good the dream is greater than
anything that I could have imagined you
know when I was a little girl my father
on Sunday morning after church he was a
deacon so he thought he had to say
goodbye to every single person we were
the last car leaving the parking lot in
the green Oldsmobile and we would drive
through the white people's neighborhoods
and I used to dream the dream driving
through the white people's neighborhood
we drive through white people's
neighborhoods and you see their fancy
houses some of them had gates but all of
them had trees and I remember when I
first came to Baltimore I met a friend
hello Baltimore in the house when I
first came to Baltimore I I made friends
with a wonderful woman named Arlene
Weiner she was a wealthiest person I'd
ever met and I went to her house and
parked in the driveway there was a
Corvette and there was a BMW and there's
a Mercedes away whoa Arlene's rich and
at Arlene's house once I got inside I
could see from her kitchen window six
trees in the front yard I thought oh
which people have trees when I get rich
I'm gonna get me some trees I'm not just
gonna get me everybody won't get cars
and pocketbooks and shoes I want me some
trees so as life would have it I was
standing in my kitchen window about
three years ago in California making
coffee in the morning and I was looking
out the window and I saw the six trees
but listen to me I was making making
vague in the coffee
I saw the six trees I went out on the
porch to actually count the six trees
and this is what I noticed that I could
dream the six but beyond the six trees
in my kitchen window or 3687 trees how
do I know because I had them counted
Adam counted that's how one know how
many trees out there I dreamed the six
that's as much as my my small mind and
my imagination could hold for myself I
dream the six but God can see beyond the
six
it's see beyond the six because there
was a bigger dream for me and I'm here
to tell you there is a bigger dream for
you essence there's a bigger dream and
so the key the secret the magic is to
surrender to God's dream for you to quit
fighting against and pushing against and
disallowing against and resisting
against and trying to tell the Creator
the universal forces divine intelligence
what you are supposed to do and get
still and know for sure what his dream
the dream is for you